[موسيقى]
لم تسع الفرحه عائله الطفل شهر لصيام
ابنها فشاهزين البالغ من العمر ثمان سنوات
يخوض تجربه صوم شهر رمضان المبارك للمره
الاولى فكثير من الاسر الباكستانيه تحرص
على تحفيز وتدريب اطفاله على الصيام منذ
الصغر في تقليد متوارث يسمى روزاكوشاي
كاملا
كل اذ كانوا مفطرين شعرت بالجوع ظهرا
لكنني واصلت الصيام بناء على طلب والدي
ومن اجل الثواب
اشعر بالسعاده لصيام ولدي كان هادئا ولم
يرثر الشكوى خلال صيامه بدانا تعويذه على
الصيام تدريجيا في البدايه كان يصوم ما
نسميه صوم العصفوره حتى الظهر وهكذا حتى
صيام يوم كامل
تمر ساعات الصيام طويله على شاهزين بين ان
اسرته تحفزه على اشغال وقته بحل الواجبات
المدرسيه وممارسه العاب الفيديو لاوقات
محدده كما تحرس ايضا على تثقيفه بالعبادات
الاسلاميه وتنميه المفاهيم والقيم الدينيه
لديه وذري حب تعلم وقراءه القران الكريم
طيله شهر رمضان الفضيل هذه اول مره يصوم
فيها شاهزين كان لديه اختبار في المدرسه
لكنه اكمل الصيام الاجواء هذه الايام جيده
ويوميا احرص على اصطحابه الى المسجد
للصلاه وتعليمه القران الكريم فنحن
كمسلمين علينا ان نعلم ونغرس في اطفالنا
حب الدين
واجبات وعادات وتقاليد لا تزال تحرص عليها
مختلف الاسر الباكستانيه تجاه اطفالها في
شهر رمضان حتى وان بدت بسيطه فهي تعني
الكثير للاطفال وذويهم الذين مروا بهذه
التجربه في طفولتهم ولا يزالون يحافظون
عليها جيلا بعد جيل
تقليل باكستاني متوارث للاحتفاء بصيام
الاطفال للمره الاولى وهو يهدف لتكريم
الاطفال الصائمين وتشجيعهم على اداء مناسك
شهر رمضان الفضيل عبد الرحمن المزيني
العربيه راهو البندي لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات